a hundred billion stars and seconds we
Traverse jumping over points of light
across the universe our accidental guide
the owl that starry-eyed Zeus the
western screech owl was found injured
after flying into a window the cause of
his downfall was his blindness this has
also caused his rise to fame as a
dazzling bird whose eyes are a window to
the universe a beautiful reflection into
still ponds looking at Zeus we also see
a reflection of ourselves and of how we
tend to see the universe and things
around us we are good at recognizing
similar structure and the big and small
the night sky is one of the greatest
storytelling panoramas and it works both
ways we see ourselves in the universe an
intertwining of the big and small with
us in the middle we see the eye of God
in a nebula and a face on the moon it's
part of our psychology the brain is a
predictive organ and we try to find
sense and noise we fill things with
information for Zeus that means he can
enjoy life as a celebrity and for our
descendants it means they will one day
reach the Stars
for it is a destination that we will
never stop seeing in our dreams and in
the world around us